i uh i want to ask you you have this new
album right now you've done
i read this today 73 albums that's
probably about right but i've been at it
a long time
can you even remember all of these no
well i i do if i hear them i think oh
yeah that was back in 02.
right right do you ever do was there
ever one of those 73 that you regretted
like you've done so much great work
because was everyone that you thought i
wish i hadn't done that one
oh you know you've always got when
you're a songwriter you think they're
all good it's like how everybody thinks
their kids are pretty even if they're
not
right right it's not my family's well
aware of that yeah
but yeah there's so i wrote this song
once about an uh it's like all oh it's
about a man that owned a bunch of oils
and i was trying to
you know marry him he says i'll always
love you i'll always care i'll always
love you i want you all wells dear
that was before i will always yes you're
like okay i'm going to work on that
throw rice i want to throw rocks at her
she took the only love i had i don't
want to throw rice i want to throw rocks
at her
but if it's terrible and that's you've
written so many great songs but like
that doesn't really roll off the tongue
i don't want to throw rice at her
yeah but it's like i'm going to throw
rice but i'm going to cook it first
right but you write all these things
remember those old songs years ago like
don't squeeze my
in and you know people used to write
that and country music was famous for it
but yeah i got some
suckers in there but i look up here your
least popular album of all time i
actually looked it up today i found it
and
it's pretty fascinating it just didn't
work
that was me as the cowboy pervert right
there
uh you know you talk a lot about how you
you grew up and you were quite poor when
you grew up and that you actually
ate things that you caught well yeah you
do in the mountains when you're country
people
it sounds awful when you read it and
people think oh you go around eating
possum and groundhog and squirrel and
rabbit but that's what you do you don't
you know you
either that or you go hungry what is it
like for example what does it taste like
what does squirrel taste like
it's good it's sweet it tastes like
chicken it
tastes like rabbit people still serve
rabbit in restaurants i've even seen
rabbits served in uh
so in central park if i see a squirrel
go by i should grab it
you'll see well i don't eat that anymore
but there's nothing better than possum
under glass
is that true no does do people eat
possibly i grew up my one of my favorite
shows of all time beverly
hillbillies and granny's always cooking
up possum and i thought is that real do
people eat possums
if you're really really in bad shape you
eat pasta my dad never would let us eat
possums he said i ain't nothing but a
damn rat
and it's true then he said pass the
squirrel yeah
i'm not eating that squirrel
right like you say you do what you do
when you're grown up like
sure now what do you do tell me what
kind of things like growing up
in tennessee what'd you do for fun if
you know there were
obviously not a lot of money to go
around and today you know a lot of
people say kids are spoiled they got the
video games and
you know movie theaters what did you do
for fun well we had lots of homemade
toys we had each other to play with
that's for sure we didn't have toys but
anyhow but we the big things for us was
like to go swimming at the sup hole
there was this um last name it was a
place
uh you know at the river that had a
bunch of rocks we had one of those in
times square and then they cleaned it up
you know
they didn't like it because it was like
a bunch of rocks and a bunch of rocks
and then like underneath there were
caves but it was like real deep cold
water
and it was the best place in the world
to swim but you could get sucked under
right and so everybody in the whole
county called it the old suck hole so
it's like you'd ask
they even had baptizings down there but
you could you could get pulled in it's
like a giant toilet you could catch
underneath the rocks and it was
dangerous your parents didn't like you
to go but you know how a bunch of rowdy
kids are but
we made it sometimes i look back on that
and i wonder how we did but it was it
was a good life
sure and you now things have gone so
well for you i know that you're a sucker
for infomercials you love infomercials
and you love to buy all
like you buy too much of that stuff is
that true i have a weakness for it
because as a kid
my grandmother was bedridden and i used
to help her spend time with her and
like brush her false teeth and take her
bed pan out no the other kids would do
it but she used to order things for me
out of the catalog
and i just got hooked on that as a
little kid in the wish book
so now i get on airplanes all those gift
magazines every infomercial everything i
see
i order it and i think when i'm seeing
it that i can't live without it and then
i get all this stuff and i think what on
earth was i think well i'm the same way
when i
fly on an airplane they have that
magazine and you're flipping through it
and they'll say
you know your dog can eat processed
cheese while you're away
like you know like they have these crazy
things that you can buy and i
it all looks good to me i know and you
and you order some of the stuff's real
good
but the biggest part of his junk but i
just have a weakness for that i think
that
a lot of you just want to have it you
see it you got it yeah do you ever call
up you see it on tv late at night and
you call and you're talking to somebody
like send me that right now do you ever
tell them that you're dolly parton
them no dolly dean which is my married
name but i do i order
every exercise machine i just hang my
clothes and my wigs on it yes i
never use it like none of us actually
use them i use mine to dry pasta
you know i just rely all on it but that
all looks good don't it sure oh yes i
get it sucker
we uh we have uh well talk about this
the new cd which of course has a
patriotic theme for god and country tell
us about the uh the record
well actually this is something i've
wanted to do for a long time and i think
this is a great time to do it there's a
lot of great
gospel type things in it too like a
piece in the valley
which bring hope and a few things but a
lot of fun things like gmail want to go
home
ballad of the green beret god bless usa
a lot of songs that i've written
and so it's a very uplifting uh album
and i thought it would be a good time
it's almost like a little
musical i talk a lot through it and kind
of set up the songs and why i did them
and
what i think they you know have the
importance of them sure
so uh i'm going to be doing one later
that's off the album
that's great i just i mean i know you're
you're going to leave now and come back
and
uh and sing for us but i wish you could
stay here on the couch
all night it's so nice having you here i
wish you could just stay i wish you
could stay for the rest of the
i show wish i could say that i'm going
to be doing a recording with norah jones
a little later so if i could stay here i
would
yeah it would be great it just be so
nice if you're sure you just can't stay
for a little while no i can't stay
honest
i'll be just it'd be great for me if you
would just i would love it if you stayed
i would stay but
if i
[Music]
should stop
[Music]
and yet i know
that i'll think of here each step
of the way
bittersweet
[Applause]
that's all i have and all i'm taking
with me that's beautiful
so goodbye please don't cry
we both know i'm not
what you need
love you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody should be back later on the
[Applause]
show
you